[SPEAKER_00]: Second of Wealsun, Jude and Paul Rivero walk to the dungeons of the royal palace of Prince John.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's actually not that far down to the dungeons, but it's in carved out of rock.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you pass several well-armed guards who salute, not salute, but like click their heels to Paul.
[SPEAKER_00]: So they know he's coming, for one, and they know he's there, which kind of tells you that Gianna has given him some kind of passage to the household.
[SPEAKER_00]: So that saying he said where I don't really interact with that family, he's obviously trusted, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: So you descend probably 50 feet down some stairs, go through a couple of barred gates that are open, and enter a dungeon that is probably too big for who it's containing.
[SPEAKER_00]: Prince Jeon doesn't seem like he likes to imprison too many people.
[SPEAKER_00]: You don't know if that's a good or a bad thing.
[SPEAKER_00]: You don't know if it's because he...
[SPEAKER_00]: Doesn't like to imprison people, or he just kills the people he doesn't like.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, one of the two.
[SPEAKER_00]: Whatever the case.
[SPEAKER_00]: You come into the area, the jailer, who seems more mild than furred, takes you to the cell and lets you into the room and says, the prisoner's behind bars.
[SPEAKER_00]: Would you like me to let him out, or would you like to question him behind the bars?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, just let us in.
[SPEAKER_00]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is he chained to the wall?
[SPEAKER_00]: He's behind the bars.
[SPEAKER_00]: The room has bars that separate it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Leave it closed.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you want me to chain him to the wall?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: Would you like me to heat the pokers?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, get them ready.
Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Heat the pokers.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, thank you.
[SPEAKER_01]: And make it obvious.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so he walks down the hall.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you have a water flask?
[SPEAKER_01]: Or a couple?
[SPEAKER_00]: I have a bowl of water.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll take that to the prisoner.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so he gets a bowl of water for you and then goes over to a cabinet and opens it up and starts picking out pokers.
[SPEAKER_00]: And will he be able to see you preparing pokers?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll walk down the hall with the pokers in hand.
[SPEAKER_00]: Like the hot ones, yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is perfect.
[SPEAKER_01]: I go in with a water bottle, or the bowl.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you guys walk into the room.
[SPEAKER_01]: I tug it down.
[SPEAKER_00]: The guy pulls his legs up and kind of looks at you, pulling his dirty shirt, not a cloak.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, you should be afraid.
[SPEAKER_01]: You remember me?
[SPEAKER_01]: Is that what you say?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, I do.
[SPEAKER_02]: I look over and say, do you remember me?
[SPEAKER_00]: This looks down.
[SPEAKER_00]: Doesn't say anything.
[SPEAKER_00]: If you whisper, go ahead and just say it, because I want to get it recorded.
[SPEAKER_01]: Are you going to do this?
[SPEAKER_01]: I whisper.
[SPEAKER_01]: Are you going to do this or am I?
[SPEAKER_02]: I thought you were going to do this.
[SPEAKER_02]: Just go, dude.
[SPEAKER_02]: Just go.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: I clear my throat.
[SPEAKER_01]: Dude, you should be afraid.
[SPEAKER_01]: Very afraid.
[SPEAKER_00]: Roll intimidation.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I think I only have this one.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_02]: I was gonna say I should not do an intimidation roll.
[SPEAKER_00]: 19!
[SPEAKER_01]: Be very afraid.
[SPEAKER_01]: He kinda looks at you.
[SPEAKER_01]: But we do not need to be unkind or uncivilized as I kind of like slosh a bowl of water and some of the water spills out.
[SPEAKER_01]: You must be thirsty as it spills out on the floor.
[SPEAKER_01]: Have you been fed?
[SPEAKER_00]: No?
[SPEAKER_00]: I would like water.
[SPEAKER_02]: Of course you would.
[SPEAKER_01]: As I drink some myself.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: God, you don't want this water.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is much, much less civilized than what you deserve.
[SPEAKER_01]: Speaking of what you deserve, you tried to accost, or you did accost,
[SPEAKER_01]: I wouldn't eat that, as an aside.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's the waxy part of the cheese.
[SPEAKER_01]: You didn't tell me that.
[SPEAKER_01]: I know I didn't.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's what I'm telling you right now.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's all right.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's going to be so great.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I wouldn't eat that.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's the waxy part of the cheese.
[SPEAKER_00]: Why?
[SPEAKER_00]: Goodness, why?
[SPEAKER_00]: I had no idea his station, sir.
[SPEAKER_00]: I just saw him as a rich merchant traveling to the merchant district, the great market.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you're a Toli rat?
[SPEAKER_00]: Is that what you're saying?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, I'm Monmurgian, sir.
[SPEAKER_00]: Loyal and true?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, as loyal and true as the city is to me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Not barren?
[SPEAKER_00]: As you said.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, you see, we're in a little bit of a pickle.
[SPEAKER_01]: We need information on the streets, but we can't trust you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, you can trust me.
[SPEAKER_01]: As I said, we can't trust you.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, who do you have to parole to us?
[SPEAKER_01]: Parole?
[SPEAKER_01]: Parole.
[SPEAKER_01]: Who do we kill if we can't get back in touch with you?
[SPEAKER_01]: If we were to use you for our services?
[SPEAKER_01]: I whip out another piece of cheese that I had hidden in my blood front.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's Prince Geo's cheese.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's good.
[SPEAKER_00]: He says,
[SPEAKER_00]: So I'm not to be executed.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, we may still have to mean it some.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know, cut your dick and balls off, open your mouth and feed it to you, but, you know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, we haven't decided that yet, because we can't trust you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Help us out.
[SPEAKER_02]: Help us help you.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're a good, solid Monmurgian citizen.
[SPEAKER_01]: I can see.
[SPEAKER_01]: Loyal.
[SPEAKER_00]: Kenneth smiles and says.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't think you can trust me.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think that the trust you can have with me, sir, is easily bought.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm going to go grab the hot metal poker.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't think he can trust you.
[SPEAKER_00]: How can I make him believe me?
[SPEAKER_01]: Who can you want for rock?
[SPEAKER_00]: Are you looking for a sister, or a mother, or a father?
[SPEAKER_00]: Leverage.
[SPEAKER_00]: It has to be somebody that you would not like to see tortured to death.
[SPEAKER_00]: What's his name?
[SPEAKER_01]: I didn't ask him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Good thing.
[SPEAKER_00]: How about my compatriot from last night?
[SPEAKER_02]: He's obviously of no value to you, seeing as how quick he ran on you, if you remember that.
[SPEAKER_01]: I whispered.
[SPEAKER_01]: I thought you were gonna let me do the talking.
[SPEAKER_02]: Just look.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know if you remember, but...
[SPEAKER_02]: He ran on you.
[SPEAKER_02]: He thinks you're dead.
[SPEAKER_02]: You did take a...
[SPEAKER_01]: A quarrel or an arrow?
[SPEAKER_00]: An arrow.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I thank you, sir, for the care that your servants have given me afterwards.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you're us.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're probably true.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's probably true.
[SPEAKER_00]: My companion probably does think I'm dead.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, he thinks your head's put on a stake out there.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's probably surprised it's not hung over the wall.
[SPEAKER_02]: Might be right here pretty soon.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sorry.
[SPEAKER_01]: You don't rank the wall.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's for people at a much higher station.
[SPEAKER_01]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_00]: The gutter.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do I rate that?
[SPEAKER_00]: Obviously I rated being brought into the royal palace.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, it's because we don't know how to use you, but we do need you use somebody to use.
[SPEAKER_01]: You just have to convince us.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's start simpler.
[SPEAKER_02]: What's your name, friend?
[SPEAKER_00]: My name is Gregory.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm from Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, that narrows it down.
[SPEAKER_00]: Originally from the dock district.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, I do live in the foreign district and do my trade there.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm assuming I also came back with the metal high.
[SPEAKER_00]: You don't have that yet, but the guy is walking back and forth with the pokers.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you believe him?
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know if I believe him.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know if I buy into this Gregory name.
[SPEAKER_01]: I whisper to him, don't get stuck on the name.
[SPEAKER_02]: If he has a family, they'll have his last name.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you know any captains?
[SPEAKER_01]: Any harbor masters?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, the harbormaster is... No, I mean, do you know personally that we vouch for you?
[SPEAKER_00]: Your character?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, he's the one.
[SPEAKER_01]: Who have you done work for?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I mean, I've done work on the harbor with captains.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've even sailed on ships.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I mean, who in the guild have you done work for?
[SPEAKER_00]: No one of name.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh my god, this guy.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is he shirtless?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, he has his shirt.
[SPEAKER_00]: But, I mean, the guy is young.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm just trying to see if he's got any tattoos or anything like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Any guild markings?
[SPEAKER_01]: Anything that would, like, you know... Has he been, like, a felon before?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, nothing like that.
[SPEAKER_00]: You can't... Bring it away!
[SPEAKER_01]: That poker will do.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's got scars, however.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so I investigate him with the light of the poker.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you say, give me the poker.
[SPEAKER_00]: Give me the poker.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's see if this lights you up and I rip his shirt off.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you want to open the bars?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I just say, come close with the thing, take your shirt off.
[SPEAKER_02]: I walk up to the garden and I ask him, I ask to see what he had on him, like anything, a wallet with his name on it or something.
[SPEAKER_00]: So basically, you want to know what he had on him.
[SPEAKER_02]: He had a dagger, a garrote,
[SPEAKER_00]: A what?
[SPEAKER_01]: A garage.
[SPEAKER_00]: A garage.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's something used to kind of strangle people.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or, if it's really good, cut somebody's head off.
[SPEAKER_00]: He had a sling and a pouch with 12 lead sling bullets in it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Take your shirt off.
[SPEAKER_00]: No proof of identity?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: He says, what is this, sir?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm inspecting you from marks.
[SPEAKER_01]: Any kind of guild marks.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: He takes off his shirt.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Turn around.
[SPEAKER_01]: Arms up.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's got a tattoo here on his back, right on his shoulder.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Roll Insight.
[SPEAKER_00]: Actually, this is not Arcana, but History.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So History is a plus eight.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thirteen.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's a member of the Thieves' Guild in the Foreign District.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ah.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can put your shirt back on.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's been a while since I've been to Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: Who's in charge these days?
[SPEAKER_01]: Jonas.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wait, that sounds familiar.
[SPEAKER_01]: Does it?
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: Are you asking him as a DM?
[SPEAKER_01]: Sorry, I was asking him as a DM.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, Jonas doesn't sound familiar.
[SPEAKER_01]: I asked it in.
[SPEAKER_01]: And how long has Jonas been in the seat?
[SPEAKER_00]: I would say eight months.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eight months!
[SPEAKER_01]: So if somebody wanted to screw Monmurg over, they would first need to get people in positions of power and authority.
[SPEAKER_00]: He kind of looks at you.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, we are being screwed over, are we not?
[SPEAKER_01]: Citizens starving in the streets?
[SPEAKER_00]: He kind of looks at both of you and goes, These things are far above me.
[SPEAKER_00]: Or the Thieves' Guild.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, I think that they might include the Thieves' Guild.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the question is, how high do your ambitions go?
[SPEAKER_00]: What exactly are you asking?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm not entirely sure if I can trust Jonas.
[SPEAKER_02]: Especially if he's only been in the seat.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's say that you lose nothing by telling me that Jonas has been in the seat for eight months.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, it seems to me that Monmurg has been a month?
[SPEAKER_01]: Has it been about a month that they've been under... A month and a half, two months.
[SPEAKER_01]: But it's gotten desperate in the last month.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, right.
[SPEAKER_01]: That Monmurg has been...
[SPEAKER_01]: Under siege in two months.
[SPEAKER_01]: If somebody wanted to screw over Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: Which would of course make you an enemy of the state.
[SPEAKER_01]: And all of the other guild members as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Unless there were mitigating factors.
[SPEAKER_01]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_00]: So... What would those mitigating factors be?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, that you were upstanding.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, maybe I'm not upstanding.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm sorry, I go too far.
[SPEAKER_01]: At least loyal to the city of Monmurg and to your profession therein.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure hope they're loyal.
[SPEAKER_01]: But the forces that are trying to collapse Monmurg, or take over Monmurg, would first need to infiltrate.
[SPEAKER_01]: I look at them closely to see if there's any, yet does he swallow?
[SPEAKER_00]: He doesn't swallow.
[SPEAKER_00]: He looks at you intently.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Like I'm dealing with a different dude.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do an insight roll.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oof.
[SPEAKER_01]: Plus three.
[SPEAKER_00]: Damn!
[SPEAKER_00]: One.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nothing.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can't read him, so obviously he doesn't swallow.
[SPEAKER_00]: Or whatever.
[SPEAKER_01]: So the question is, how compromised is the guild?
[SPEAKER_01]: That's what I need to know.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you want to serve, and more importantly, keep all of your body parts.
[SPEAKER_00]: To be honest, the Guild is suffering like everyone else.
[SPEAKER_00]: The trade, as poor as it is.
[SPEAKER_01]: But desperation makes sense.
[SPEAKER_00]: We're desperate.
[SPEAKER_00]: To be honest with you, I think we never would have gone after this man
[SPEAKER_00]: I'd said the situation been better.
[SPEAKER_00]: Honestly, definitely we wouldn't have done it with two people.
[SPEAKER_00]: I would have hired a prostitute to guide him into an alleyway if I'd had the coin to do so.
[SPEAKER_00]: What do you think of Jonas?
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, does he do a good job?
[SPEAKER_01]: As well as his predecessor?
[SPEAKER_01]: Given, of course, the circumstances and the trying times.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or does he make unusual decisions?
[SPEAKER_00]: I think he takes too much of the tough power, to be honest with you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, but greed is predictable.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, that's fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: And especially if it's in hard times, that makes even more sense.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm saying, does he favor any particular advisors?
[SPEAKER_01]: Does he favor any particular areas?
[SPEAKER_01]: Areas?
[SPEAKER_01]: Does he call certain areas or certain people as persona non grata?
[SPEAKER_01]: Don't touch them.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, of course, the rule of court.
[SPEAKER_00]: Which you violated.
[SPEAKER_00]: To be honest, we couldn't identify the man.
[SPEAKER_02]: We had no idea who it was.
[SPEAKER_00]: Still did.
[SPEAKER_00]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have no idea who this man is.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're talking about saving your life and in exchange for information.
[SPEAKER_01]: The information must be valuable to us and we must be able to predict your behavior.
[SPEAKER_00]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, Jonas...
[SPEAKER_00]: Leaves alone those men who pay the bribes.
[SPEAKER_00]: As always, are there new men paying bribes?
[SPEAKER_01]: New men being in the last year.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is this about the Toli?
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe.
[SPEAKER_00]: Are the Toli paying the bribes?
[SPEAKER_00]: The Toli have been all over the foreign district these last four months.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can you identify all of them?
[SPEAKER_00]: And are they working with Jonas, or at least with his protection?
[SPEAKER_00]: Jonas has nothing to do with them, but he stays away from them, of course.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's a death warrant to deal with... You know the names of any of them?
[SPEAKER_00]: Toli Nobles.
[SPEAKER_00]: The name Kane Toli has been bantered about quite a bit.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're not talking about Nobles.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're talking about noble Toli henchmen.
[SPEAKER_00]: These are Toli assassins.
[SPEAKER_00]: They are nobles.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, wait.
[SPEAKER_00]: Pause.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is that news to me?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wait, so you're telling me that it's a family tradition?
[SPEAKER_00]: It's well known that the magical assassins from Port Toli are trained in assassination and magic.
[SPEAKER_00]: And there have been several of them in the foreign district over the last four months, coming and going.
[SPEAKER_00]: Why is it a death sentence?
[SPEAKER_00]: To attack them?
[SPEAKER_00]: Not to attack them.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, it's as criminal as me attacking him.
[SPEAKER_00]: The Toli family will not have their own touched.
[SPEAKER_00]: If there's some rumors that you wish, just don't be so obtuse.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ask me blatantly.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you can trust me.
[SPEAKER_02]: We're looking for Toli rats.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're looking for Toli rats, but apparently the Toli rats, he's saying, are nobles that are not... Toli rats come and go.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're all over the place.
[SPEAKER_00]: These are not the men you care about.
[SPEAKER_00]: You care about the assassins, the nobles.
[SPEAKER_01]: Which you said are all over the foreign district.
[SPEAKER_00]: They had been.
[SPEAKER_01]: Four of them.
[SPEAKER_01]: To what purpose?
[SPEAKER_01]: Is there anything that you can glean?
[SPEAKER_00]: They are asking questions.
[SPEAKER_00]: They are looking for...
[SPEAKER_00]: They're trying to find particular people.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're meeting with people.
[SPEAKER_00]: Spending money.
[SPEAKER_00]: Large amounts of money.
[SPEAKER_00]: Their actions have not been quite, as you say.
[SPEAKER_01]: How long have you been with the Guild?
[SPEAKER_00]: I've been with the Guild ever since I was 10.
[SPEAKER_00]: Roughly how old is he?
[SPEAKER_00]: He's probably around 17, something like that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Strangely enough, all of them have left Monmurg maybe seven days ago.
[SPEAKER_00]: All of the Toli assassins?
[SPEAKER_00]: All of the nobles, Toli nobles, yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: How do you know that?
[SPEAKER_00]: They're easy to see.
[SPEAKER_02]: I wish.
[SPEAKER_02]: What's that?
[SPEAKER_02]: How are they easy to see?
[SPEAKER_00]: They're Suel.
[SPEAKER_00]: They have rings.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's from the street.
[SPEAKER_01]: I believe them.
[SPEAKER_01]: Which is a start.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'd buy that.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you're beyond journeyman, or up to journeyman?
[SPEAKER_00]: At least, yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you get a say, or do you have the ability to talk to Jonas directly?
[SPEAKER_00]: I can speak with him.
[SPEAKER_01]: This might work out much better than either we thought or you thought, meaning there could be a substantial amount of wealth involved for you specifically, but we would need to meet with Jonas.
[SPEAKER_01]: As non-Guild members, we understand that that would be
[SPEAKER_00]: I could easily arrange a meeting if it were guaranteed he would not be in danger of his life.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think the only thing that he would say no to... is being caught.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, truthfully... On a ship in the bay?
[SPEAKER_00]: Perhaps the meeting?
[SPEAKER_00]: A ship in the bay?
[SPEAKER_01]: Would that be safe enough?
[SPEAKER_00]: What kind of ship?
[SPEAKER_01]: Not one of the Prince's fleet, obviously.
[SPEAKER_02]: All guns.
[SPEAKER_00]: Perhaps in the Grand Market?
[SPEAKER_00]: On trade day?
[SPEAKER_00]: Would that be acceptable as well?
[SPEAKER_00]: Do I know about that?
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, it's just...
[SPEAKER_00]: I know.
[SPEAKER_01]: It would normally be really crowded, but since we're all kind of fucked up and things that has the Grand Market been a little bit spartial.
[SPEAKER_02]: I was there recently.
[SPEAKER_02]: There's, like, hardly.
[SPEAKER_02]: Not much there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: But still, it's like an open area, safer, whatever.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, you could still march towards him and grab him.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's outside.
[SPEAKER_00]: But what he's looking for is a place where he can escape if he wants to.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's not going to march up to the dungeon and want to have... How long has Jonas... You said Jonas has been in charge for about eight months?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: And can you... Well, do you trust him as far as trust goes within your... Well, like I say, he takes more than his cut.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, if you would go for someone of his caliber, but you wouldn't go for one of the Toli, who are obviously an outsider?
[SPEAKER_00]: I didn't know who he was.
[SPEAKER_00]: The Mask?
[SPEAKER_00]: He was not wearing this mask, in fact.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I was.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, you were wearing that weird thing that when he attacked you- No, I wasn't.
[SPEAKER_02]: I had taken it off.
[SPEAKER_00]: I know, I know.
[SPEAKER_00]: When he attacked you, you were.
[SPEAKER_02]: But before that, you were wearing that weird sort of plastic mask.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, I wasn't.
[SPEAKER_02]: Before- When you walked from the- No, because as soon as I got out, as soon as I left that market, as soon as I said it- When you walked, you were being followed when you went from the royal place down to the- When I first went there, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, wait a minute, wait.
[SPEAKER_01]: I actually have a question.
[SPEAKER_01]: What is that mask to you?
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, for prooffully, or it'll be your own dick in your hand.
[SPEAKER_00]: There are rumors.
[SPEAKER_00]: There are rumors of foreign spies.
[SPEAKER_00]: They wear that mask.
[SPEAKER_00]: That mask?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is that where you got it?
[SPEAKER_01]: Secondhand?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I got it from the marketplace, Jude.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you even know what that mask is?
[SPEAKER_02]: There was a second one if you wanted to know.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you know what that mask is?
[SPEAKER_02]: It's a mask out of the...
[SPEAKER_02]: I know that the monks wear it or whatever, but not really, no.
[SPEAKER_01]: So when you say that you wouldn't have messed with him, you're assuming that by his mask that he's one of the... No.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let me explain.
[SPEAKER_00]: We saw this man come from the Royal District.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, he was not wearing finery.
[SPEAKER_00]: He was wearing the clothes of common clothes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Put away the pokers.
[SPEAKER_01]: We need more wine and cheese.
[SPEAKER_00]: He was wearing common clothes as if he was a trader.
[SPEAKER_02]: When I first walked in, I looked normal when I was leaving the market.
[SPEAKER_00]: He did not look normal.
[SPEAKER_00]: He had a large coin purse on his side.
[SPEAKER_00]: You probably didn't even know that.
[SPEAKER_00]: It jingled.
[SPEAKER_00]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_00]: It was obvious.
[SPEAKER_00]: And so he made a very, very good target.
[SPEAKER_00]: We followed him.
[SPEAKER_00]: There was something strange about his face.
[SPEAKER_00]: It looked like a normal face, but it didn't move.
[SPEAKER_00]: It had no expressions.
[SPEAKER_01]: More cosmetically human.
[SPEAKER_00]: He was not wearing this mask.
[SPEAKER_00]: We watched him in the marketplace.
[SPEAKER_00]: He bought this mask off of a trader and then put it on, as if not knowing what it was.
[SPEAKER_00]: I knew what it was.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's a trader in the marketplace selling these masks?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's the one you should be talking to, not me.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, we will.
[SPEAKER_00]: And we will still be talking to you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_00]: But truthfully, I have no idea who he was.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, that's fine.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's fine.
[SPEAKER_00]: We just were interested in the money that he had.
[SPEAKER_01]: Where is the stall for the trader that sold the mask?
[SPEAKER_01]: And tell us where your friend has his drinks every night or where he beds with his woman.
[SPEAKER_01]: To begin with.
[SPEAKER_01]: But I like how this is going.
[SPEAKER_01]: As I said, put away the pokers!
[SPEAKER_01]: Get some more of the wine, the good stuff, not what you're drinking.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, there is a bar.
[SPEAKER_00]: Known as the Homely Wench in the foreign district.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's where you'll find Jonas, but if you would like, I can... Jonas?
[SPEAKER_00]: That's who you wish to know about, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I did, but I also said your compatriot, who was the other assailant.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, he's there too.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So the Homely Wench...
[SPEAKER_01]: And you said Foreign District, so it's a bar called the Homely Wench in the Foreign District.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's near the Grand Market Wall.
[SPEAKER_00]: Am I roughly familiar with that?
[SPEAKER_00]: You're more towards the dock side of things, but you know.
[SPEAKER_01]: And what was your friend's name?
[SPEAKER_01]: Or, his handle.
[SPEAKER_01]: What does he go by?
[SPEAKER_01]: If we had to ask for him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Jobs.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And where was the stall that sold the mask?
[SPEAKER_01]: What part of the market?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, well, yes, that's true.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sorry.
[SPEAKER_01]: Stupid question.
[SPEAKER_00]: The man was from the East, some Southern country, maybe the Spender Thiles.
[SPEAKER_01]: I would like to be able to trust you, and even more importantly, and you can believe this, to use you, and to use you frequently for information.
[SPEAKER_01]: That I think that you can understand.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's say that we work for a gesture in the place where you're being held.
[SPEAKER_01]: And we need to ferret out those agents that you're talking about, that you said that they left.
[SPEAKER_00]: Probably a week ago.
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe five days.
[SPEAKER_01]: I can't imagine that if it was a source of information that they would leave not someone behind.
[SPEAKER_01]: And that's what we would need to know.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, there is one agent.
[SPEAKER_00]: Or someone, we think.
[SPEAKER_00]: That you believe to be, at least.
[SPEAKER_00]: She's new to the city and she's been hanging around.
[SPEAKER_00]: She... She became...
[SPEAKER_00]: A resident around the same time they did.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, I'm thinking, do you know what I'm thinking?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can you describe her?
[SPEAKER_00]: An elf.
[SPEAKER_00]: Somewhat attractive.
[SPEAKER_00]: She's pretty, I would say, elusive.
[SPEAKER_00]: She knows when she's being followed.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's obvious she's some kind of operator.
[SPEAKER_00]: There are rumors about who she walks with, talks with.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, she has been seen near Lord Jamis' fortress.
[SPEAKER_00]: So we're not sure quite who she is.
[SPEAKER_00]: Does she work for Lord Jamis?
[SPEAKER_00]: Does she work for the Toli?
[SPEAKER_01]: If we chose to forego speaking with Janus, how do you feel about being our man?
[SPEAKER_01]: That can carry significant weight and significant consequences if you get found out, at least by your own guild, unless I'm wrong.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, unfortunately, if I show up, then I'm... Oh, you'll be beat, bloody.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, I mean like, I guess maybe being beat bloody wouldn't be enough?
[SPEAKER_00]: I think that would be fine.
[SPEAKER_00]: Roll an inside roll.
[SPEAKER_01]: 14.
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe not.
[SPEAKER_00]: Break his nose.
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe something has to be gone.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cut in here.
[SPEAKER_00]: But obviously he doesn't want to talk about that.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, you have the guard pick him up, so when he gets rolled out he needs to be...
[SPEAKER_02]: He can be a Lousineer, a finger...
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, unless we want to have him go directly to Janus and make a deal, in which case Janus, being the guild master... Jonas, sorry, would be able to provide him some kind of protection, or at least the excuse... Um...
[SPEAKER_01]: What is the standard punishment?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do I even know?
[SPEAKER_01]: I should know.
[SPEAKER_00]: Attapping to somebody in the royal family?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, that's death.
[SPEAKER_01]: I would say if he didn't know, then maybe the street didn't know.
[SPEAKER_01]: So let's just say where he got dragged to, somebody that could have been at least connected to a bird.
[SPEAKER_01]: So what is it?
[SPEAKER_01]: Does he have to lose a hand?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, that's what I'm thinking.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Could be a foot.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, no, you can't do a foot.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you do a foot, he can't even.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's gonna hobble around.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's gonna suck.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, he's gonna be...
[SPEAKER_02]: Which hand would you prefer to lose?
[SPEAKER_01]: Or, do you have a better solution?
[SPEAKER_02]: He's definitely going to go.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, we can take your offhand.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, you know, I would hate to take your, you know, dominant hand.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'd suck.
[SPEAKER_02]: We're going to learn how to write out.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, it might ingratiate you to a life of serving the Crown.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, in truth, Jobs is the only one that really knows what happened.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I don't know how many people saw myself being taken by the guards.
[SPEAKER_00]: How about this?
[SPEAKER_00]: I said that they thought I was dead, they threw me in the body pile, and that I crawled away.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's true, you did shoot him in the throat.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, but then I bandaged him right after.
[SPEAKER_02]: Not bandaged, you just kind of did that.
[SPEAKER_02]: I put my stinger in it, and then I bandaged him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Trust me, that's hardly bandaging.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're not lucky.
[SPEAKER_00]: In fact, that's probably the best story, in which case they think I'm dead.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's not bad.
[SPEAKER_01]: How do we make sure that you don't disappear on a song?
[SPEAKER_01]: Where would I go?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well...
[SPEAKER_01]: It's not that.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's whether or not you'd sell us out.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, we can afford to pay you.
[SPEAKER_00]: How would I sell you out?
[SPEAKER_00]: Who would I sell you out to?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I mean, we need to still stay in contact with you, so you would sell us out to, I don't know, whatever the female you're talking about is.
[SPEAKER_00]: The female agent?
[SPEAKER_00]: What possible money would she give me for the information?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, by the way, I was questioned by Paul Rivero and some mysterious person in the dungeon of the royal palace, and they asked questions about the Toli that were walking around the foreign district.
[SPEAKER_00]: Wait, what?
[SPEAKER_02]: Who questioned you?
[SPEAKER_00]: Is he saying he questioned him?
[SPEAKER_00]: Two men.
[SPEAKER_02]: Who?
[SPEAKER_00]: Guards?
[SPEAKER_00]: Two guards.
[SPEAKER_00]: What do they look like?
[SPEAKER_00]: Um, standard Oeridian guards.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm talking of the guards that question me right now.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like guards from the Royal District?
[SPEAKER_01]: Guards from the city?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, obviously just him.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he points to the guy with a poker walking back at the floor.
[SPEAKER_00]: Obviously not the two of you who questioned me.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're saying two other... Two other people who questioned me.
[SPEAKER_00]: But actually that's not what I would say at all.
[SPEAKER_00]: What I'm trying to say is I wouldn't sell you out.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's no reason for me to sell you out.
[SPEAKER_00]: I just don't believe that.
[SPEAKER_00]: I would tell the story of the fact that I was dumped in the body pile.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, it's okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I would probably sell you out.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm fine with that.
[SPEAKER_01]: I understand how that goes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to go talk to him?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: We'll do that right now.
[SPEAKER_02]: Talk to who?
[SPEAKER_01]: The guy walking around with the poker to find out who the other two were.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, what the guy was trying to say was this.
[SPEAKER_00]: How would I explain the fact that I, you know, let's say, what he was trying to say is how would I sell the two of you out to some agent?
[SPEAKER_00]: Would he say, I got questioned in the royal palace by these two guys?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, you'd say one wearing a mask.
[SPEAKER_00]: What he's trying to say to you, Jude, is he's trying to basically say his story, after saying he was thrown on a body pile, would be valueless, at best, and ridiculous, and more likely than anything else.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's just trying to make an argument for the fact that he doesn't know how he could sell you out.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think that we need to establish contact with Janus, and I think this is our guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Jonas.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I think this is our guy.
[SPEAKER_02]: Clearly.
[SPEAKER_01]: We can play airway.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can leave with both hands.
[SPEAKER_01]: You'll be paid upon a successful meeting with Janus.
[SPEAKER_01]: Successful meeting, of course.
[SPEAKER_01]: You'd have to be able to convey we're not interested in him, obviously.
[SPEAKER_01]: As you can tell, we're interested in the Toli assassins.
[SPEAKER_01]: And what they've been doing.
[SPEAKER_01]: And it sounds like perhaps you guys know perhaps more.
[SPEAKER_00]: If at any time you think that Janus is being bought off by them, that would probably... Do you want me to go and contact him as an agent, or do you want me to try and investigate whether or not he's working for Dully?
[SPEAKER_00]: Both.
[SPEAKER_00]: Investigate first.
[SPEAKER_00]: How will I be in contact with the two of you?
[SPEAKER_00]: Ferd's bar.
[SPEAKER_00]: Talk to Ferd.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_00]: Really?
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you know Ferd now?
[SPEAKER_00]: I know the bar.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't go into that big hole.
[SPEAKER_00]: Only the worst go there.
[SPEAKER_00]: You should be right at home.
[SPEAKER_00]: Slayers.
[SPEAKER_01]: That gives you something to be worried about with us.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, Ertz.
[SPEAKER_00]: When?
[SPEAKER_01]: How long do you think you'll need to investigate if Jane is disconnected with the Toli Scum?
[SPEAKER_00]: Five days.
[SPEAKER_01]: Five days it is.
[SPEAKER_01]: What would you like for payment?
[SPEAKER_02]: Money.
[SPEAKER_02]: They can serve the food.
[SPEAKER_00]: Money.
[SPEAKER_02]: Definitely.
[SPEAKER_00]: And food.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, food.
[SPEAKER_01]: How much money?
[SPEAKER_00]: 50 gold coins.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Done.
[SPEAKER_01]: Depending upon the value of your information, depending upon the proof that you can bring, the validity of it,
[SPEAKER_01]: We'll start off with five gold coins.
[SPEAKER_01]: And of course, if it leads to much more.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sky's the limit.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right, we have a deal.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do I know anything about the Thieves Guild from hanging out with, you know?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, in fact they are, so you know that the Assassin's Guild was killed by Gowl.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, so this guy's probably pretty much straight Thieves Guild, and I get that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, because I do remember being there for that, at least, and it was a while ago.
[SPEAKER_01]: But...
[SPEAKER_01]: That's what I need to know.
[SPEAKER_01]: I need to know if the Toli Assassins are trying to re-establish the Assassins Guild.
[SPEAKER_01]: I need to know if Janus is taking money from them to not harass them.
[SPEAKER_01]: If he's on their payroll.
[SPEAKER_01]: Which, mind you, we might be able to still work with him.
[SPEAKER_01]: But, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you need besides a good old black eye or two?
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, or is it just the, you know... Well, I thought we would just throw me in the body pile.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thug me enough.
[SPEAKER_00]: I wouldn't have to get beaten or lose my hand.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Too easy.
[SPEAKER_02]: No way.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's got to at least get the basic beaten, like everybody.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, maybe you died during the beating.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just one.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, one time.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was actually thinking originally maybe multiple times.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And of course we will pay for any extra damage.
[SPEAKER_02]: We can fix things like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, from the beating.
[SPEAKER_02]: We'll have you beat and then we'll throw you in the body pile.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's like douse like you know like his like rags around his neck with a lot of blood like the beating like when they tried to get it out of him like he obviously bled to death.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: That way if anybody did see him and saw what you did and saw the guards take him, they'll be like oh they tried to beat like information out of him but he bled to death because he took an arrow in the throat.
[SPEAKER_01]: By the way, good job.
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys' aim suck though.
[SPEAKER_02]: But that's like...
[SPEAKER_01]: You might want to stick with dagger work.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, your dagger.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do the dagger next time, bro.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know what you were doing with the sling, bro.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know if it was you that missed the first shot or what.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, obviously, the real allure here for you is just simply riches.
[SPEAKER_01]: But that should be enough.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, quite honestly, it should be enough.
[SPEAKER_00]: Honestly, sir, it is.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's kind of what I'm thinking.
[SPEAKER_01]: That could go pretty far.
[SPEAKER_01]: Don't be discouraged.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I'll come by Ferd's Bar in the next three days, I'll be there.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I'll go in once every other day after that.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm not going to hang around that bar.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, you shouldn't hang around that bar.
[SPEAKER_00]: I would be killed.
[SPEAKER_00]: Why would you be killed?
[SPEAKER_00]: The mercenaries that hang out there?
[SPEAKER_00]: They wouldn't have me there.
[SPEAKER_01]: When you come in, ask for the still.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then you can hang out in there.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then Ferd will know that he needs to send a runner.
[SPEAKER_01]: If we're not there.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you'll talk to the bartender?
[SPEAKER_00]: This Ferd?
[SPEAKER_00]: Of course, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: We'll let you shake your hand if that means nothing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Guards?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you doubt that we have the coinage?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, I doubt you have the coinage.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just making sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is there anything that you're concerned about?
[SPEAKER_00]: The beating.
[SPEAKER_00]: We'll tell them to go for bruises.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's so broken bones.
[SPEAKER_01]: No broken bones.
[SPEAKER_02]: I appreciate that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Don't take it personal, like I said.
[SPEAKER_02]: I wouldn't be surprised if you got broken enough.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll bring a healing drop for you in three days if it happens to be anything more serious than just some bruises.
[SPEAKER_01]: But, are you cleared?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you have any questions about us?
[SPEAKER_00]: None.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And should Ferd's place end up being burned to the ground for some reason?
[SPEAKER_01]: We, of course, you know...
[SPEAKER_01]: I have a photographic memory, so... Yeah, alright.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so the two of you walk out.
[SPEAKER_01]: You totally got no pokers.
[SPEAKER_02]: Give them the basic beating.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basic beating, no broken bones, throw them in the body pile.
[SPEAKER_01]: No gouged eyes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Guards!
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so where do you guys want to go now?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, what do you got for your next thing?
[SPEAKER_02]: Again, we can just wander the foreign district with the Immoculate.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, I also grabbed the Immoculate.
[SPEAKER_01]: Why don't we go put under surveillance the boots where you got that and maybe don't wear that?
[SPEAKER_00]: What is the problem with the mask?
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so wait a second.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's what I'm gonna say.
[SPEAKER_00]: You guys walk upstairs.